mon fils il va te PDG de la société
et ma fille elle va être
dans les parages
elle veut vivre comme Faudel
Nicolas très bien et vous qu'est-ce que
je suis content de moi aussi ça
franchement ça me fait plaisir ça va
tout va bien tout va bien
pour ton retour
sans déconner tu aurais pu tomber pire
je dis pas ça
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
Jean-Marie toi qui a des enfants aussi
est-ce que tu sens qu'ils sont à moi ils
sont à fond mon fils il veut être
humoriste il invente des blagues ah oui
allô
je te raconte une blague papa pour la
grosse rigolade et qui arrive bientôt et
il me raconte une blague qui l'a inventé
il me dit c'est un mec qui s'appelle
Nick et il a perdu sa maman et il
raconte ça son pote et son petit frère
oh nique ta mère
ça va alors ça dépend de la Stila 10 ans
elle a 10 ans
elle est motivée pour travailler c'est
pas ce qu'elle veut faire plus tard mais
ça motive pour travailler on travaille
ensemble quand je l'ai le weekend et
tout ouais et très motivé pourquoi tu as
fait une accélération comme ça
le mec tu sais tu vois partir là-bas et
alors
je vais prendre l'héritage de mon père
il y en a pas beaucoup donc
[Rires]
mon fils il fait un bac chimie pourquoi
tous les tout le monde des enfants
travaillent bien sauf les miens
travaillé le fruit tombe jamais
travaillé peut-être que et moi comme
j'ai pas j'ai arrêté l'école à 15 ans du
coup j'ai j'ai forcé j'ai dit ah les
gars ton fils fait un bac chimique et ma
fille elle a eu son bac agricole fort
pour exploiter une ferme
et là il m'a fait une arnaque de portes
ouvertes là pour prochain lycée ils
m'ont emmené dans une journée portes
ouvertes à 8h30 du matin à l'autre bout
de l'Oise en fait c'est juste parce que
la meuf qui kiffe elle faisait les
portes ouvertes elles faisaient visiter
le lycée qu'il est parti au McDo avec
elle j'étais comme un con dans le lycée
à marcher
à regarder des trucs de méthanol de
regarder ça c'est des experts quand vous
jetez de la poudre ça détecte le son
c'est pourquoi parce dans le sang il y a
du fer oh c'est pas mal j'étais comme un
con à dû faire un tour de chimie
mais les mecs
[Applaudissements]
[Rires]
j'avais dit Pascal j'avais dit je sais
pas ce qu'on fait il m'avait dit on va
faire hippocampagne parce que dans le
lycée où on était dans l'Essonne il y
avait Cocagne et il y avait que il m'a
dit il y a que des filles en hypogne et
il y avait 40 personnes on était trois
ou quatre mecs et 36 filles c'est réglé
un jour tu étais le beau gosse de
l'école oui c'est pour vous dire j'étais
le beau gosse de la classe donc
j'ai flingué ma scolarité pendant 2 ans
j'ai l'impression que vous avez vraiment
envie de parler parce que c'est pour
revenir au truc pendant 2 ans j'étais
tellement taré que j'allais pas dans ma
classe moi j'étais amoureux d'une fille
qui s'appelle Véronique Josse et je suis
vais Véronique Josse partout
j'avais science maths j'allais en
musique
et je prenais une flûte à un mec on voit
que Véronique Joss là on on imagine là
on voit que Véronique José normalement
elle est sur allez on a l'expert en
communication Véronique José lors du
Sénégal
il a quand même été regardé sur Facebook
mais c'est normal ça se croise non non
non les copains qui te met en
connaissez-vous machin toi
j'ai fait 2 ans à me balader dans des
classes que j'avais rien à dans
cette classe en fait incroyable moi j'ai
fait comme Raymond mais c'est bon
[Applaudissements]